lara croft the iconic female action hero
burst onto the video game scene
25 years ago with guns blazing and
pickaxe in hand she continues to inspire
new generations today
this year marks the 25th anniversary of
tomb raider and we are
so excited to celebrate alongside fans
throughout 2021
over the years lara has uncovered lost
tombs solved ingenious puzzles
survived treacherous traps and saved the
world many times over
she's also become a pop culture icon who
has inspired countless fans around the
world to embrace their adventurous side
and to just keep moving through
challenging times
we have some exciting partnership news
to celebrate lara's 25th
including the recent reveal of a tomb
raider anime series in collaboration
with netflix and legendary television
and talent updates for the next big
screen installment of tomb raider
featuring alicia vikander
lara's also all over the gaming space
and we're working with talented teams on
crossovers for tom clancy's ghost recon
break point
and war of the visions final fantasy
brave exvius
what is the lost valley statue is also
progressing extremely well and we can't
wait to share the final paint with you
in the coming months
and we're thrilled to announce that a
tomb raider cookbook is coming later
this year from inside editions
which will allow fans to bring recipes
from lara's global adventures back home
we're also announcing today a new
digital bundle that will give the world
a chance to play lara's reboot adventure
in its entirety
the tomb raider definitive survivor
trilogy follows lara's origin from a
survivor to the modern day tomb raider
we've only just kicked off lara's
25-year festivities so keep an eye on
our social channels for more nostalgic
content fan celebrations and exciting
surprises throughout the year
if i don't survive
none of us will
[Music]
i've come so far
i'm not turning back
get ready
[Music]
what would you do
and on our way out we have one last
surprise you've seen that lara croft has
now arrived in fortnight
but that's not the end of our epic
collaboration croft manor is coming to
fortnite creative as a playable
adventure on march
23rd alliance studios has been hard at
work on the hub and we can't wait for
you to play it next week
be sure to check out
fortnitecreativeandfortnight.com on
march 23rd to learn more